salut comme vous me l'avez demandé
plusieurs fois depuis quelques mois on
est en train de se faire une semaine
spéciale micro expressions c'est à dire
que tous les jours je prends une micro
expressions et je vous explique comment
elle fonctionne quelles sont les codes
les muscles qui rentrent en marche et on
est déjà à la 6ème micro-expressions à
savoir le mépris si jamais vous avez
raté les autres depuis lundi sachez que
dans la description je vous ai mis un
lien vers une playlist qui regroupe les
sept micro expressions dont on a parlé
cette semaine
un mépris c'est un petit peu mon préféré
parce qu'il est imbattable c'est la
seule micro expressions qui est
asymétrique sur le visage c'était
d'ailleurs on peut pas la rater cette
micro expressions s'affiche sur un
visage quand quelqu'un se sent supérieur
à une autre personne quand elle se sent
plus forte qu'une note ou quand elle
estime qu'elle est supérieure sur un
acte d'autres personnes ou sur le
personnes en allemagne les muscles qui
rentrent en jeu sont les lèvres dia le
muscles zygomatiques les lèvres qui
remonte mais comme cette asymétrie qu'à
un seul côté de la lèvre qui va remonter
un petit peu comme dans cette vidéo de
démonstration
là on voit bien que le verbal et le non
verbal ne disent pas la même chose
l'unité d'action numéro 10 selon le
codage de paul ekman se relève en
asymétrique donc la lèvre supérieure ça
dure moins d'une demi seconde comme tout
les micro-expressions on peut donc en
déduire qu'à ce moment précis
nicolas sarkozy méprise soit le public
qui en train de faire du bruit pendant
qu'il parle soit la personne dont il
parle donc françois hollande soit les
personnes qui ont voté pour françois
hollande c'est une de ces trois
hypothèses est également présent dans
les signes du mépris a le menton qui se
relève et la tête qui se redresse vers
l'arrière prend une position comme ça
une espèce de léger mouvement de recul
jeudi j'ai eu un commentaire très
intéressant qui me demandaient si on
pouvez simuler une micro expressions
alors oui et non les deux réponses en
même temps oui dans le sens où si je
mets en marche toutes les unités
d'actions qui correspondent à une micro
expressions précise alors je serai en
train de la simuler c'est le cas des
comédiens c'est le cas également de paul
ekman qui est capable de contrôler tous
ses muscles un par un et donc de les
associer pour faire une micro
expressions il ya une maîtrise complète
de ses muscles faciaux ça me permet
d'ailleurs de revenir sur la vidéo de
jeudi avec le sourire vrai le sourire
faut que je vous demandais d'analysé en
réalité les deux sourires étaient
simulées parce qu'ils étaient faits à la
demande mais il y en avait un qui
faisait rang
c'est toutes les unités d'actions d'une
vraie joie et sur l'autre et manqué
certaines de ses unités d'actions et si
vous repassez la vidéo celle de jeudi
donc je vous invite vraiment à le faire
vous placez votre main sur le bas du
visage des personnes vous ne regardez
que les yeux vous cacher le bas de
l'écran
et là vous verrez ça va vous sauter aux
yeux qui en a un qui a les yeux rieurs
et l'autre pas du tout c'est pour ça que
je vous donne pas la réponse directe
elle sera flagrante quand vous passerez
la main d'oeuvre et non on ne peut pas
simuler une micro expressions dans le
sens où les signaux apparaissent de
manière incontrôlable iran - un quart de
seconde
ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'on peut
maîtriser dans une conversation
d'envoyer se signale aussi rapidement et
de les passer aussi rapidement en
faisant marcher toutes les bonnes unités
d'actions ensemble c'est pour ça qu'on
peut le simuler oui pour donner
d'expression complète durant un laps de
temps assez long et réfléchi mais on
peut pas le simuler le faire apparaître
dans une conversation comme une vraie
micro-expressions merci beaucoup d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo je ne sais même plus
à combien on est dans le mental blog je
vous rappelle le défi de basse et faire
une vidéo par jour du 1er janvier au 31
décembre
ça va pas dire que j'arrêterais les
vidéos l'année prochaine vous le savez
si vous avez regardé la vidéo que j'ai
fait pour les cent mille abonnés demain
en clôture les micro-expressions où je
vous parle de la tristesse et la semaine
prochaine on se fait une petite semaine
de tarés avec des trucs très intéressant
donc par exemple une petite
mentalisation de doc cévennes je crois
que ce sera mardi penser à liker cette
vidéo avant de partir et surtout à vous
abonner ça se passe par ici et par ici
et rendez vous demain à 11 heures
ciao
l'abcès